hi I'm Eric Voss and this is the
breakdown of legions second episode
chapter two that's right I love the show
so much that I'm hoping to do weekly
episode breakdowns of it no promises now
if you haven't seen my breakdown of
episode 1 go check it out because a lot
of the random stuff we saw in that
episode actually starts to make sense in
this episode I also get a lot into who
Legion is and the x-men comics and how
that backstory might connect to this
show but chapter 2 had plenty of visual
clues and Easter eggs of its own and I'm
going to break down everything that I
caught so let's get started with these
opening images this episode opens with
this interesting montage of David with
Sidney and Melanie and her team as they
float downstream away from these
pursuing soldiers from division 3 and
the first thing that struck me was the
cinematic look of all this we're back at
that same wide aspect ratio that we saw
in David's hospital call foot chase
memory last episode and I think once
again a cinematic widescreen if used to
suggest that David is out in the open in
danger and I actually think there's a
specific film that this opening montage
is trying to evoke notice how we hear
this brooding narration from David knows
a while we'll scratch our heel this is
the only time this show so far is used
narration at the device and I think it's
deliberate so that narration combined
with these surreal cross-dissolve
transitions over shots of a boat
floating down a river I think this is
all an homage to the Vietnam War film
Apocalypse Now and in both that movie
and Legion a suicidal man goes on a
journey into his own damaged mind with a
bunch of colorful psychedelic visuals
and a yellow toned ball the demonic
figure waiting for him Colonel Kurtz and
the devil with the yellow eye and let's
talk about this song that we hear
this is a cover of the Talking Heads
road to nowhere that's a song about
joyfully looking forward to the rest of
your life and eventually your death and
looks like closely to the lyrics and
[Music]
this is exactly what David's experienced
in here he knows where he's going the
Summerland facility but he doesn't know
where he's been because his memory is
impaired he doesn't know which of his
visions or delusions and which actually
happened and this episode is all about
memory David's attempt to perceive what
happened to him without getting sucked
back into the pain of those moment and
before I move on I was trying to figure
out who this singer is and I might be
totally wrong but to me this - sounds
like the singing voice of Aubrey Plaza
Lenny
stolen from Nathan you know the song
again just the theory and I'm sorry if
I'm not crediting the real singer here
but if this is Aubrey Plaza what an
interesting choice it would be like
Lenny is this voice from David's past
haunting him that whatever path he's on
it's going to lead to the same place
that she ended up yeah okay moving on we
learned that the man in the green suit
from last episode is called the AI now
that's probably referring to his one eye
which you may remember looking kind of
weird when David flipped out last
episode and I'm still not really sure
what this guy's deal is
visually he's often associated with dogs
like maybe he's a mutant that hunts down
other mutants some people are saying
that he looks similar to Jason Stryker
and x2 but considering how Legion is
kind of avoiding a lot of the movie
timeline stuff I don't want to go too
far down that path and notice how after
David moves from the dangerous outside
world into this new Summerland place the
aspect ratio changes implying that David
is no longer on the run he's in a safe
place now Melanie gives us some context
of what was going down last episode that
the division facility is a place where
mutants are held and experimented on and
then she says this life the human race
you need to even now it's still not
totally clear when the series takes
place but if the human race is just
beginning to evolve I feel like this is
at the earlier part of the x-men
timelines maybe before mutants have
really gone public however that doesn't
really tell us what year it is like the
fashion and hairstyle still seem very
1960s by the technology says otherwise
like the MRI was invented in 1977 and a
few more things that I liked here I like
how am L aney gets David to focus by
having them listen to the one female
voice in his head that's calling his
name which turns out to be heard here
you can come up man in the next scene
with Sidney notice how David's hair is
sticking up I feel like that's a
reference to legions appearance in the
x-men comic where his hair is often
shown straight up okay moving on to this
first memory work session as putana me
and Melanie take David into his memories
notice these metal handles to me this
whole process looks a lot like auditing
and Scientology so honor dating is where
an individual known as a pre-clear has
to answer a series of questions about
their pasts while holding similar metal
rods from a device called an e meter and
then notice what Melanie says
here I mean you clear clear is a
Scientology term meaning free from
unwanted emotions and painful traumas on
a subconscious level called impact now I
should say I'm not trying to spread
Scientology doctrine and actually think
most of the stuff is complete horseshit
and I don't think the show Legion has a
Scientologist subliminal message either
but this does cast kind of a suspicious
light on Melanie and her method like I
don't think she's a villain but let's
face it David it's still
institutionalized trapped in this new
facility just like clockwork it's just
that this cage is nicer and it looks
like it has a better chance of helping
him but we still don't fully know
Melanie's agenda yet now when David
looks back on his memories the faces of
his parents are never shown so why is
that it could be that David did
something terrible to them like maybe he
killed them and its memory is still
trying to block that out but honestly if
we're going to talk about David's
parents we have to talk about the
biggest thing about David Hall is Baxter
in the comics and I apologize that this
is already pretty widely known David
Haller is the son of Charles Xavier so
does that mean that this man reading
David the bedtime story is Professor X
it's possible I mean telling the son
that he's an astronomer kind of sounds
like a potential cover story and the
consolation lamp projects light on the
wall similar to the way cerebro looks
but I personally don't think this is
Professor X like he's not English and
he's not in a wheelchair in the comics
Professor X wasn't really there
throughout David's childhood like they
didn't really know each other until way
later in their lives
so unless David's memory was mapping
over professor X with this image of
another guy it isn't him but another
theory is that these two people are not
David's biological parents they could be
foster parents whom David was left with
and the reason he can't see them in his
memory is his psyche is telling him that
he never actually knew who these people
really were to him now as David relived
the terror of this book that's not at
all safe for kids
notice how we hear this unsettling music
staying and that's the same sound effect
that we heard in the first episode
whenever the devil with the yellow eyes
appeared
now I'll talk more about the devil with
the otherwise in a bit but this show
definitely wants us to associate the
moments of David's greatest fear with
that demonic character okay moving on to
the office of dr. Poole and if you
remember last episode dr. Kissinger
implied that David did something
terrible to this guy what happened when
I what I did to dr. Poole you went off
your medications now you probably
noticed the weird glitch in the scene
like an editing jump in the middle of
David talking now the episode explains
why this happens later but this is
another example of Noah Hawley using
camera trickery who suggests that
David's perception of his own memories
is bias and self-censored he blocks out
the moments that cause him pain then
notice David's clothes as he walks out
of the office this is the same outfit
that he wore in that brief shot last
episode when we saw him eating spools of
audio tape and I'm guessing that we'll
see more this in the future but it looks
like after David attacked dr. Poole
maybe to get money for drugs like Lenny
suggested then he might have just chewed
up all the record of this encounter
erasing it from his memory and I think
the shot here of David chewing on the
twizzler is meant to remind us of that
image now Lenny is sitting in front of
this large mural of Larry from the three
stooges and I think what's most striking
about this portrait are his eyes I mean
really when you think about it eyes are
following David throughout this whole
episode the eye tasting them in the
woods
Larry's eyes and this other set of
graffiti eyes in the next shot and I
think all these eyes symbolize David's
flawed perception of his memories that
he needs a third party to explain to him
what really happened now moving on there
were a lot of interesting things going
on in this scene between David and
putana me first putana me hands him a
glass of milk which is another Stanley
Kubrick reference the opening scene of a
Clockwork Orange and in that movie the
characters drinking milk symbolized
their immaturity and adolescence they
were like still infants nursing on milk
and I think that idea of infancy and
Maternity is running throughout this
scene with putana me like notice how
they both drink milk and then fatahna me
gives David this vivid description of
his memory from being inside of the womb
how loud and suffocating it is until he
saw the light and I think he's trying to
relate with David here implying that his
current state is merely a womb a
preparatory stage for the next step I
mean his true self
imagine you cumin
sad your mother's body warmed and blind
and then get this intense pressure and
suddenly light also yeah there's a
stuffed white mountain goat watching
over them and many cultures mountain
goats are symbols of fertility and then
a few other little things I noticed in
the scene briefly David sees flashes of
a woman wearing a red dress that could
be Sidney or Amy or his mother or
someone else not really sure what to
make of that yet also over the PA system
we hear a few announcement it is kind of
sound like just fun random jokes like
the time travel class was canceled
because Legion does not want open that
can of worms just yet the x-men movies
have time travel covered okay moving on
outside on the swing set
Sidney explains to David what she saw
when they swapped bodies including this
quick shot of the devil with yellow eyes
now in my last breakdown I talked about
how the devil is part of David's psyche
and identity that manifest his fears and
I still think that but there are a few
other options of who this guy could be
based on the x-men comics first he looks
a lot like the character mojo now mojo
is a slaver who runs the mojo verse
which is like a reality TV network with
gladiator likes program but that
character was really just like a parody
of network TV executives and I don't
think the devil with the yellow eyes is
mojo however the devil could be based on
the shadow king now the shadow king is
the guy who inspired Professor X to form
the x-men he was spawned by the first
nightmare and he represents the dark
side of human consciousness feeding off
of other telepaths and using them to
fight other people and it was the battle
between Legion and the shadow king in
the comics that left Legion in a coma
now again I don't think Noah Holly is
that concerned with referencing the
x-men comics but I could see how these
characters might have inspired the
character of the devil with yellow eyes
now another thing that I noticed in
Sidney's memory which might have been
the first episode but I just didn't see
it is the logo of the clockworks
hospital a dog with a clock in his mouth
and back that dog statue looks super
similar to the carving that I made last
episode in division 3 and this might
support the theory that a lot of people
have that the clockworks mental hospital
was really just another layer of
delusion inside David's mind or it could
be that this hospital is just under the
control of one of the divisions which is
why the eye is seen
the strings later on when Amy gets taken
into the hospital okay fact forwarding a
bit when David and Lenny scores some of
this vapor drug notice the windows at
David's apartment they look like eyes
this is another example of how David's
own perception is unreliable meeting the
third party to verify everything and
that's why we see fatahna me and Melanie
recognizing to specifically traumatic
memories that David has been blocking
out seeing Lenny as the devil PLO eyes
during the drug trip and flashing back
to his kitchen exploding while talking
with dr. Poole that was the glitch that
I talked about earlier and then while
trying to explore that second one
David's memory takes them all to this
childhood fear of the angriest boy in
the world book so the through line
connecting all these moments is David's
fear he was afraid of the book and
whatever happened to his parents or
parental figures and then as an adult
that fear has evolved into the devil
with the yellow eyes notice how even
that fear in dr. Poole's
office later takes the form of a cliche
childhood image of horror the monster in
the closet okay moving on this episode
shows David begin to be able to control
his powers so like as he talks with
Sidney he uses telepathy to read her
thought you aren't Keys down and then
later while in the MRI david astra
projects to his sister who's looking for
him in the hospital and then notice how
when david gets trapped in the MRI this
whole sequence kind of reflects photon
amis description of what it was like for
him in the womb it's a loud
claustrophobic space a feeling of
pressure and then a flash and I think
this is meant to show David's angst to
move on past this transitional phase and
to have control over himself finally
unfortunately the midwife's waiting for
him on the outside is the fear that
freedom comes with the devil with the
yellow eye the possibility that the most
demonic savage part of his psyche will
take over if he ever goes out in the
world on his own and if you look back
that loss of self-control is something
that's been haunting David all episode
notice how we can hear in the MRI
growling like an animal and that sound
is a combination of other animal growls
that we've heard like the barking dog'
and Allie and the roaring lion face on
the armrest before when David was
tripping on the vapor
and we should know that doctor didn't
see and it's final cliffhanger where we
learn that the eye isn't silent after
all shall be and while David continues
to work with Melanie and plot a rescue
attempt for his sister he knows where
he's going but he still doesn't know
where he's been okay some lingering
questions one do you like the vagueness
and mystery of this show now I think
it's a pretty bold choice to challenge
the viewer by withholding
straightforward storytelling from us
instead making us piece together
David's reality through this sensory
experience but personally I prefer it
this way rather than the typical hey
look how fun it is to have superpowers
story legion really depicts how being a
mutant is actually more of a curse at
least for now and - do you think Legion
should be more connected to the x-men
comics like as interesting as the shadow
king is I just don't think we're going
to see these characters show up in
literal forms on the show so it kind of
forces us to ask ourselves what's more
important in our superhero adaptation
stand service and on-screen adaptations
of characters that we know and love or a
story that's really only concerned with
getting in the head of one specific
character let me know what you think in
the comments and thanks for watching and
make sure to check out my breakdown of
the first episode and really if you want
to see more of these Legion breakdowns
we need you to share this video and keep
the conversation going
also please hit like and subscribe to
new rockstars and make sure you're
getting email notification and then if
you really like it you can contribute to
us on patreon thank you so much to all
of our current patrons you guys are
amazing
especially math you solve out you can
hit me up on Twitter a TA box with any
thoughts or theories that you have about
Legion or follow new rock stars on
Twitter at new rock stars for updates on
our videos alright thanks for watching
bye
so super responsive e-commerce it